make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and as
we continue to make up our own what-if
stories in this video we're covering
what if the beyonders invaded the DC
Universe now before we get into the
actual story I wanted to offer some
background on the beyonders for those
who might not be familiar so the
beyonders are an extremely powerful race
of aliens that exist in Marvel Comics
but actually exist outside of the main
Marvel multiverse
now when Jonathan Hickman took over the
Avengers and New Avengers he used the
beyonders as the antagonist of his time
runs out storyline which centered on the
destruction of the multiverse and what
we found out was that the universes are
basically colliding with one another in
a series of what are called incursions
and the main Marvel Universe is in line
to experience an incursion of its own
and all of that turns out to be the work
of the beyonders who are basically
conducting an experiment to find out if
they could destroy the multiverse it's
also revealed that the beyonders have
killed some of the most powerful
entities in the Marvel Universe
including the Living Tribunal who's
regarded as the second most powerful
entity in the multiverse behind only the
one above all so suffice it to say the
beyonders represent an enormous threat
to the very existence of not only the DC
universe but the entire multiverse
now as for how it would play out if the
beyonders came to the DC universe I
think it would first have to center
around the greatest collection of
superheroes in the DC Universe the
Justice League and so the story would
open in the midst of the Justice League
Watchtower seemingly on a normal day
when suddenly Martian Manhunter who's
the only one man in the watchtower at
the time gets an alert of a major
abnormality in the distant reaches of
the universe
now remarking that it is far enough away
to not be a major threat to earth at the
moment he feels that it's worth checking
out due to the size of the energy
signature that's left and so he contacts
the rest of the Justice League and
informs them that he's going to
investigate the cause of the disturbance
now the other members of the Justice
League acknowledged this but basically
go on about their business and simply
wait until Jon Jones comes back with
information now a few hours pass and
finally the Martian Manhunter returns to
earth and calls an urgent meeting with
the rest of the week and as a reports is
finding it's obvious that what he
observed
shakin him but even more importantly
he's not alone with him our mr. miracle
and big Barda new gods from the Planet
of New Genesis now they explained that
what caused the phenomenon that Martian
Manhunter observed was the destruction
of earth 34 which lies next to prime
Earth or earth zero the earth is home to
the main DC continuity as it exists now
now the New Gods have basically been
monitoring the situation from New
Genesis and explained that in addition
to earth 34 six other Earth's
within the multiverse have also been
destroyed but they are simply too far
away from prime Earth for the Justice
League to notice now after what's
causing the destruction the New Gods
explain that the source of this havoc is
more powerful and different in nature
than anything they've ever seen and it
seems to come from beyond the multiverse
itself so Batman would ask the question
how do we stop this from happening and
then mr. miracle will reply we don't
we've tried we sent troops we said gods
we've sent everything we can think of to
the earths that they've targeted and no
one ever comes back whatever they are
wherever they're from this is way more
than we're capable of dealing with now
Superman would interject and say that's
not an acceptable answer whatever this
is
there has to be a way to stop it and
we'll find it and mr. miracle tries to
argue but Barda ends up cutting him off
we hope you're right she says for the
sake of all of us and so scot-free and
big Barda would end up returning to New
Genesis to keep monitoring the situation
agreeing to stay in contact with the
league as they formulate a plan to
tackle this new and unknown threat now
the league is ultimately in agreement
that they need to reach out to any
allies they have who might be able to
shed any light on the situation
Wonder Woman will reach out to her
fellow members of the Justice League
dark for any possible magical solutions
and Hal Jordan will look up Jim Corrigan
better known as the spectre due to the
time that Hal himself previously spent
in that role and so the rest of the
league would set about gathering as many
super-powered beings as they can knowing
that they'll need as much firepower as
possible but even then it likely won't
be enough
now Wonder Woman ends up reaching out to
John constant that he'll have picked
some information from the back channels
of the magical community but he hasn't
and says it he's happy to poke around
and see what he can find and just then
Diana gets a message from Bruce and she
can tell immediately that the
isn't very good now she would ask Bruce
Wayne what is it and Bruce Wayne would
reply it's happened and she would say he
wasn't able to find the Specter was he
and Bruce would tell her he found him
this Specter is dead now at this point
the heroes would realize that this is a
game changer the spectre is one of the
most powerful entities in the DC
Universe and is powered by the Vengeance
of God himself and they end up surmising
that the spectre found out what was
coming and went to try to stop it but
the fact that whatever they're facing
was able to defeat and kill the spectre
is cause for alarm and the reason why is
because if they can kill someone imbued
with the power of God himself then
Wonder Woman would end up musing to
herself who or what could defeat them
and at that moment John Constantine
of course lighting a cigarette would say
maybe we should be looking in a
different direction and so from there we
cut to the Hall of Justice where most of
Earth's heroes have gathered to be
briefed with what intelligence and Lee
has been able to gather and we see that
it's not only heroes that are in the
Hall but some villains as well
these include Lex Luthor Sinestro
Brainiac and even Darkseid is there
having realized that the very existence
of the multiverse and everyone in it is
at stake and so everyone has to
basically be on the same side and so at
this meeting the Justice League lays out
what they've learned after being in
communication with New Genesis and a
series of reconnaissance missions out
into the multiverse and they fill in the
rest of the group that these beings who
they've basically decided to call the
beyonders since they're from somewhere
beyond the known multiverse have been
traveling throughout the multiverse
destroying universe after universe
apparently bent on destroying the
entirety of existence and based on the
pattern they've been moving in Prime
Earth is their next target so the time
to launch an offensive is now now at
that moment Lex Luthor would chime in
and say but what makes you think that we
will fare any better than the rest of
the Earth's dead and Darkseid would
reply the Earth's didn't have me and so
then you would get or meet and he end up
finding out this comes from a little
squeaky voice where mr. Mixel pedelec
appears out of thin air and Superman
responds and saying let's hope it's
enough and then begins detailing the
plan of attack but most of the group can
tell by the tone in his voice that it
won't be enough and so we cut to space
for nearly the entire
of the DC Universe is standing ready in
anticipation of the arrival of the
beyonders we have Earth's heroes and
villains the new gods the various
Lantern Corps and I do mean all of them
the guardians of the universe and even a
reality warping fifth-dimensional and
putting their differences aside and
joined around the common goal of
preserving all of their existences and
as soon as the beyonders arrive the DC
Universe hits them with everything they
have and they get absolutely demolished
even the heavy hitters Superman
Darkseid Martian Manhunter are barely
able to affect the beyonders at all and
if this seems unrealistic just remember
that when the beyonders came to the
Marvel Universe they not only destroyed
all the heroes but cosmic abstracts like
eternity master ordered Lord chaos and
even a Living Tribunal the only way the
Marvel Universe was able to survive this
was by harnessing the power of all the
molecule men throughout the multiverse
to defeat the B honors and it was
revealed that the beyonders actually
created every version of the molecule
man and put one in each universe to
essentially function as a bomb that they
would eventually detonate and destroy
those universes so for the DC Universe
to emerge victorious from this conflict
they're going to have to find something
or someone that can produce that kind of
power so the question becomes is there
anyone in the DC Universe that can rival
the raw power of the molecule man and I
think the answer is yes and that's where
Wonder Woman and Constantine come in
when Constantine learned of the spectres
death and suggested that they go in a
different direction he was referring to
none other than Lucifer Morningstar who
as the name implies is literally the
devil of the DC Universe now he was an
angel named Sam nail who led a rebellion
against God and was cast out of heaven
he ruled over Hell for a bit until he
got bored with it and gave up the keys
he's one of the most powerful entities
in the DC Universe and that's who
Constantine tries to recruit to the
cause of saving existence and he agrees
to go with Wonder Woman to observe the
battle mostly out of boredom but when he
gets there he sees the carnage this
ensued and he sees the heroes fighting
valiantly and still getting destroyed
and he declines to intervene now he
could help he admits and he estimates it
he could likely defeat to be honest but
the question is why would he no matter
what happens he'll continue to exist
he's eternal he always has been and he
always will be and if this universe is
destroyed
he can simply make a new one that he
likes better after all he's done it
before
now Wonderwoman tries to reason with him
yells at him and even pleads with him
but nothing works he's determined to sit
this one out and so it appears that all
is lost but then all of a sudden a white
light emanates from Lucifer and he
explodes spreading light as far as the
eye can see engulfing everyone and
everything in existence including the
beyonders and then we flash back a few
hours and see a conversation between
John Constantine and a moustached man in
a bowler hat and so at this moment John
Constantine starts talking and says
everything that you have created will be
destroyed and your son isn't going to do
anything about it
you know that now the man Ponder's this
for a moment and says not willingly but
at the end of the day he'll obey his
father whether he wants to or not now
many of you probably recognized the man
talking to John Constantine here as the
presence who is essentially the god of
the DC Universe the analog to Marvel's
one above all and the creator of the DC
Multiverse
or at least we thought he was until
Snyder's run on Justice League and I
think that for the beyonders to be
defeated the presence is going to have
to get involved and seeing that his
creation is going to be destroyed in its
entirety he decides to intervene and the
mechanism by which he does this is by
destroying one of his angels Lucifer
now when Lucifer's twin brother Michael
was killed it released enough angelic
energy to destroy and remake the entire
universe and the presents used this
opportunity here to remake the universe
once again and so essentially if the
Beyonder showed up in the DC Universe I
think it would be treated as another
crisis that resets DC continuity I know
a lot of people expected that to happen
at the end of Secret Wars which was a
culmination of the Beyonder storyline in
the Marvel Universe but ultimately
Marvel decided against that for reasons
that nobody will ever fully understand
however we've seen over the years that
DC is far more willing than Marvel to
reboot their universe as they've done
multiple crises and they've done
flashpoint leading up to the new 52 as
well as rebirth all of which rebooted
their continuity completely were made
substantial changes and so what I think
would end up happening is the presence
would take most of the DC characters and
create a pocket universe to hold them
just before you destroy the beyonders
and the universe
he creates a new universe to his liking
he would repopulate it with the elements
he wanted to preserve and other change
or discard the rest and that's how I see
this basically playing out something
this huge in the DC Universe would be
cataclysmic and they would most likely
not do something that had to involve the
presence and Lucifer and a mainline DC
story unless they were going to shake up
the status quo in a major way but let me
know what you guys think about this or
what if story let me know what you guys
think about this the B honors invading
the DC Universe and ultimately being
destroyed by the presence what you think
is really cool okay that's what would
have happened if the one above all it
intervened he would destroy the
beyonders anyway guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
- comments explained make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace okay I want to
give a shout out to Kyle B David Joseph
Ben John h aj Matt and Jeff are John H
lean and mean which is an awesome name
Jason see Austin s Austin a Joey M
Steven Z Austin B Adam K and Genesis 9:6
team remember guys you could send me
messages and I'll run off whatever your
message is at the end of the video so
long as there's nothing crazy but if you
want to put a message in there send me
an email Rob at Robert Jefferson calm
and if you're one of these people who
get shoutouts then i will tack it in
there and yeah they should watch you
guys
[Music]
[Music]